you know why by professional lights when
you have a desktop computer sleeps isn't
hip and it's daytime but no the Apollo
hi guys welcome to your one super
Wednesday on its grace and today I have
something very exciting for you if you
could not already guessed by the title
of this video it's the official extended
Camp Takota trailer I have a new channel
on this channel has yet to feature I
came to code a trailer on it and we have
created a really [ __ ] awesome
extended trailer I'm gonna stop talking
and I need you to watch it
now with your brain and body both open
they'll close the body keep the brain
open
oh look at you all grown up getting
married in two weeks love you before you
know it you'll be driving your little
ones up to Dakota for the summer
yourself and I think my ovaries just
winced this might be totally
inappropriate but I finished my book it
deals with unrequited love and Loch Ness
monsters what do you don't know I just
got fired I'm grossed out sad about this
now only the change of the ears you
literally have not changed a bit in
eight years
welcome back business casual now what
are you doing here
it's embarrassing no the fact that you
peed your bunk till you're 11 that's
embarrassing
watch where you squat dumb dumb you've
got poison ivy oh wait what's Jared
doing here after this year your kumbaya
crap it's over like that hairdo on the
side pony and it's a classic thank you
as much as we don't like to think of it
as such Dakota is a business I know that
Dakota isn't the prettiest girl to dance
she's our girl all the dirt must go kill
all the squirrels we have a problem this
camp is in rough shape please shut your
beautiful beautiful face
[Music]
you go back home and he tried to tell
people about camp you have all our
inside jokes and the songs that only we
know and you end up just saying you had
to be there
I hate it when the summer ants got say
goodbye to my best friend can't code I
love you so and I don't know fresco
[Music]
that was cool it's a real movie that's
coming out on Valentine's Day please
please please that you pre-order the
film at Camp Takota dot-com
I gotta go I'm just I'm messy it with
feels I gotta clean myself up I don't
know
[Music]